procedural tv shows are built around
lovable characters and a deep sense of
familiarity
shows like ncis and its forebears have
remained successful for such an
impressive number of seasons because
they depict the same characters solving
a weekly problem
in a way that's true to their
established core not messing with the
formula is so
intrical to the survival of these shows
that the whole genre is named after a
word meaning to do things by the book
ncis fans reward that consistency in
unshakable core with their viewership
and the series has maintained relatively
high ratings even as it approaches its
400th episode
that incredible fan energy has a
downside however
what happens when you introduce a change
to your tried and tested formula
what happens when something about a
character is altered in such a way that
even die hard fans
stop and wonder just what happened in
this vein there's one
ncis change that's far more
controversial than
all the rest and still likely to cause
debate among fans nearly a decade
after it happened timothy mcgee's voice
federal officer drop your weapon though
actor sean murray has portrayed mcgee
since the beginning of the series
the actor switched to a raspy growl
around the series eighth season
the resident geek among the
investigators went from a soft-spoken
computer expert to a gruff
and hard-nosed investigator it's not
exactly what i was expecting
but this change has gone entirely
unexplained in universe or out
leaving fans to have it out over the
issue even as the show heads into its
18th season
curiously the change in timothy mcgee's
voice came around the same time that the
actor playing him made some positive
changes in his life
sean murray lost a considerable amount
of weight in between seasons and his
sister haley apparently even chimed in
on twitter to say that he had quit
smoking
taken together it's entirely possible
that the change in murray's voice for
mcgee came as a result of his weight
loss and better living
some fans have taken this as a plausible
reason behind the shift in his voice
one reddit user speculated losing all
that weight and quitting smoking can
affect a person's voice
another said this is also around the
time he got super skinny maybe that has
something to do with it
as it happens there's actually some
pretty solid science to back this up
there have been a number of studies
conducted to examine the effects
obesity has on the voice as well as what
significant weight loss can do to it
according to dr rena gupta the director
of the division of voice and laryngology
at cedar sinai medical center
excess weight can actually lighten a
man's voice gupta writes
excess weight results in an increased
production and storage of female
hormones
and to a lesser extent male hormones in
men there is a relatively higher level
of female hormones and they respond to
this
this can result in a slight lightening
of the voice while murray was in no way
obese
during ncis early seasons the extra 25
pounds he was carrying around could have
had an impact on the sound of his voice
all that said another contingent of the
ncis fandom believes mcgee's raspy voice
is part of a concerted effort to
separate him from his earlier nerd
characterization
and turn him into a more grizzled and
cool detective most fans are in
agreement that the change in mcgee's
voice came along with his newly spelt
look but some hold out that the gruff
voice is part of a larger attempt to
make mcgee cool
and a failed attempt at that one reddit
user writes
the voice is part of his new cool image
they made him boring
another poster cast doubt on the
validity of the weight loss theory
saying that the change is simply too
stark to be anything but intentional
they wrote weight loss may change the
voice but definitely not to that extreme
regardless the controversy is clearly
not enough to derail the ncis fandom
with both the flagship show and its new
orleans-based spin-off secured for
further seasons
it looks like mcgee and his new voice
are sticking around for the foreseeable
future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one